I'm back here with Pete cumin again and
impede I'd like to talk a little bit
about the user experience and what it
was so important for Optimizely to get
right about your users experience sure
so when we started Optimizely we set out
to make an a/b testing platform that
anybody could use and in fact our slogan
was a be testing you'll actually use and
we weren't the first people to build an
a/b testing platform people have been a
be testing frankly since the days of
mail catalogs you know back in the early
1900's the approach that we took to it
was that products were out there that
let you do this but they're really hard
to use and for that reason most people
just weren't doing this kind of
optimization and this insight came my
co-founder spent nine months or ten
months working on the Obama campaign in
2008 and he was the director of
analytics there and he ran a bunch of
a/b tests for the campaign and those
tests resulted in a lot of additional
money and a lot of additional volunteers
being captured by the campaign and the
insight coming out of it was hey this is
really valuable but boy that was tough
that was a pain in the ass and so that
was kind of the insight that we started
with and we just thought there's
probably an easy way to do this and so
our approach from the outset was this is
a problem that's sorry this is something
that's already out there it's our job to
make it much much easier and so we had
to focus on the user and we built a way
to to create and run an a/b test in a
very visual way we tried to design it in
such a way that a marketer who didn't
have an engineering background could do
yeah so we definitely say it was more of
like a pain killer idea to solve
someone's pain point around using a/b
testing platforms than anything else
absolutely so is I mean and in fact what
we discovered was that the pain that was
there was so significant that most
people just weren't using this product
and so at the outside our biggest
competitor was not some other company
trying to sell a product our biggest
competitor was non consumption yeah and
these companies just they'd heard about
a/b testing but and some of them had
tried it they just never were able to
get it to work for them and that's
that's what we tried to solve